president biden's backyard
looking like a war zone yet again two
people wounded
after a gunman sprayed bullets in a
crowded dc neighborhood
panic diners running for their lives and
customers inside forced a duck and cover
behind their tables the police chiefs
furious about what happened
and slamming liberal policies for
allowing violent criminals to be on the
streets
i'm mad as hell about this and i hope
y'all are too we have a vicious cycle
of bad actors who do things no
accountability
and they end up back in community and
the police officers and i guarantee you
when we lock up
whoever did this they will be no
stranger to us i promise
you that you cannot cuddle violent
criminals
you cannot you cannot treat violent
criminals
who are out here making communities
unsafe for you for your loved ones for
me for my loved ones
they might not want a job they might not
they might not need services what they
may require
is to be off of our streets because
they're making it unsafe for us
and it only took bullets flying in their
own backyard for the liberal media to
care
this of course after cnn hosts
previously mocked the surge in violence
you listen to conservative media you
would think that you know
entire cities are just you know enrolled
in
fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner
in new york city tonight people actually
walked up to us and said thank you for
i watch you every night i can't believe
they thought they did to do a double
take at us actually
hanging out and not seeing us on the tv
screen oh my god but notice the change
in tone when jim acosta's fancy dinner
got erupted last night
jim you just i guess happened to to be
there and what did you see what did you
hear
yeah anderson i was having dinner uh at
a restaurant that's very popular in dc
the diplomat people
probably heard of it uh it's on 14th
street in northwest washington
all right graham just trying to picture
myself in jim acosta's shoes where
people had just died people were running
scared for their lives gunshots
everywhere
and i was mentioning that i was at a not
a restaurant
a very popular restaurant i'd name
dropped the restaurant wasn't even
english
and maybe maybe you've heard of it it's
a national broadcast
it's not a local broadcast i would just
say i was having dinner around the
corner right
i wouldn't be sprucing the dinner up
with all of these superlatives
you know i don't like to swear in the
five o'clock hour
but i don't know if you could find a
larger ass than jim acosta
this is
cnn has been engaging in a cover-up of
violent crime for
quite a while they did it for political
reasons they did it because they wanted
biden
in there were people dying and they were
laughing about it
uh those two clowns cuomo and lemon were
actually
they were mocking people that were
concerned about the crime they were
laughing about it
remember the guy it's a microcosm of
this whole situation the guy on twitter
during the riots he was an espn reporter
or a contributor
and he he tweeted burn it down until the
riot got to his
uh breached his community his gated
community and what did he do he called
9-1-1
i said this on this on this uh table a
while ago i said it's not until
the crime affects the national media
that they will make it a national story
until then it's always going to be just
a local story
it's only and it's also of course into
acosta uh
point here it's only of interest because
they can put themselves
into the story so it's it's an ego
driven story
it's now at the restaurants where they
dine don lemon so you should be really
worried
uh crime doesn't exist until it gets in
their face do you remember when
the protests were happening and people
like maxine waters and everyone
you got to get in their face well maybe
they were right
the crime has to get in their face right
the crime had that's the only way they
understand it is if it's in their face
lastly
i i love that i love that uh police
chief was
amazing just amazing said it all better
than anybody could
what i don't get is when leaders talk
about uh announcing a crackdown on crime
so what does that imply that you weren't
cracking down on it before
it's like when an airline pilot says
we're gonna catch up in the air
it's like why can't you just go fast the
whole time and maybe i'm naive
but it's like saying i'm going on a diet
next week which meaning i'm not eating
why can't we just be this way all the
freaking time
and it's because the elite activist
class doesn't let you do it
and so you have these poor guys that are
doing trying to do their job and you
have people dying
but jim acosta it disrupts his dinner
and he gets to tell you where he was
and uh and and and chris eliza gets to
talk about the great seats he had at the
baseball game
until they can top put themselves in the
story it won't matter so maybe
the thugs should be doing more work in
their neighborhoods
well if if lemon he's probably having
dinner on the upper east or upper west
meanwhile across the river in brooklyn
it's a slaughterhouse yeah and as a
reporter he should be able to see
what's bigger than himself katie greg
mentioned the police chief
he doesn't see crime the police chief
sees
criminals and there's a big difference
there and he's saying it's the bail
reform
it's the lack of sentencing and it's the
lack of prosecutions he's saying i need
a little help here guys
yeah he's talking to the the broken
justice system in dc which refuses to
keep these guys behind
bars and the feds have a role to play
here too with charging them with federal
crimes because they're a lot more afraid
of going to federal prison than they are
going to local jails where they know
they're going to be let out
and what he said was whoever did this we
will know who they are which is an
indication that they have a pretty
uh familiar relationship with these guys
but i have a friend who has a business
right on that corner my husband was
there
last night he pulled up right when it
was happening and the truth is that
there have been 108 murders in
washington dc
this year alone the city has been a hell
hole of crime
since last summer for a year and
it's not just that this is is some city
somewhere this is the capital
of the united states of america and i
can't tell you how many people have
called to say hey i really want to bring
my kids to dc
should i come and the answer has been no
for a year because it is
unsafe it is is being run by criminals
and you can't go to dinner without
getting either accosted by blm activists
with their bull horns while you're
having dinner outside
or now you have a risk of being shot if
you if you go out to dinner in a
normally safe neighborhood and so the
question is where's the accountability
for the
prosecutors and for the mayor for
example who says
oh i'm going to put more cops on the
street after the national shooting
outside the national stadium
well more cops on the street are
completely worthless if they're not
going to be prosecuted
and kept behind bars and i loved what
the police chief said about
these guys don't want jobs they are bad
people who are wanting to do violent
things to innocent people
and they need to go away and your
thoughts are
my thoughts are that i think it's going
to be really interesting to see
what new divisions or fissures come up
between mayors in these big cities and
police chiefs the prosecutors
of people that are elected by the
populist that tends to lean left
and what the police chiefs the people on
the ground are actually saying and
we're going to see what happens in just
a few months when eric adams
becomes mayor of new york city and who
he appoints his police
chief and he was elected by the same
coalition that joe biden was elected by
so
that's older black voters um a lot of
older white voters as well
liberals who are concerned about the
crime issue that's what he led with
and he said we can have reform but we
can also make sure that we are pro
law enforcement and make sure that this
becomes a force that people want to join
again and where they can feel safer on
their streets he had that great line
about
you know white people waking up to alarm
clocks and black and brown communities
waking up to gunshots and i think that
that dialogue is going to happen in all
these major cities you've seen it
in the task force that was down at the
white house you had a police chief
from st louis from chicago and they're
speaking very differently than their
mayors are so that's really what i'm
watching here it's obviously a travesty
it's really scary these are all places
we could have been at you know going to
a baseball game
going out to dinner even at a place
that's not american as you say
um but it's terrible i've probably been
to that stupid restaurant
and i bet you liked it i probably loved
it i probably did
i hate that word dialogue i really do
because
we need to arrest and prosecute and put
away
people who kill people or commit violent
crimes eric adams has a tall order
they're um closing rikers island that's
the plan
there are thousands of people who've
been released from rikers island this
the city prison here um they need to
it's going to take
a lot to roll back all of the things
that has created this cascade of
violence here in new york city
whether it's not enforcing the quality
of life crimes whether it's the bear
reform
i digress but to greg's point
this perfectly illustrates the soft
bigotry of liberals and particularly the
left-wing media
they only get serious and give a smidgen
of a dam when violence gets close to
them when
they s when a horrific act gets close to
them
initially the defund and demonize the
police movement
impacted lower income neighborhoods
minority neighborhoods
of the very places where people of color
live
and that's where the criminals were most
brazen
now it's everywhere and now all of a
sudden because jim acosta that
repulsive bag of gas goes on tv
and can name drop this restaurant that
he was in i didn't think he
could become more noxious but he managed
to do it and
the police chief in d.c was talking to
the liberal leadership right everybody
needs to get in their faces
in this way ask them how many murders
are okay with you
here in new york city is it is it 2200
what we had 30 years ago how many rapes
are okay how many robberies are
okay but and by the way the biden
administration the justice department
can do something
you go after gang activity gun crimes
80 percent of gang activity involves
narcotics those are federal crimes
you can go in prove it's a racketeering
organization and actually prosecute
murders
that maybe say a kim gardner and st
louis won't prosecute
or the d.a here sai vance outgoing so
biden could do something if he cares
yeah but trump supporters they're the
real
violent criminals january 6 insurrection
that's right
those are the people that are a priority
for this administration